well folks it's friday january 9th and
you've tuned into gamespot news top five
the weekly show where we're running down
top five stories of the week and if
there are more than five great stories
during the week well tough
big news this week for fans of mobas and
esports and big prize monies as valve
announced the dates of the international
the dota 2 tournament will kick off in
seattle on monday august 3rd and
culminate with the championships on
saturday august 8th the 16 teams will
vie for riches and glory with the last
year's prize pool topping 10 million
dollars including 5 million bucks just
for the winning team
nice
and if you happen to win that crazy dota
money perhaps a 300 controller will seem
like a sensible purchase at ces this
week madcatz announced the links a
controller designed to be used with
mobile devices tablets and smart tvs you
can bust it apart and put it back
together in a bunch of different ways as
you can see and many of the formations
look vaguely crab like in addition to
the industry's standard controller bits
like sticks and buttons and triggers it
also has a microphone and comes with an
attachable qwerty keyboard
google released the top 10 youtube
search terms for 2014 and wouldn't you
know it people love minecraft coming in
at the number two most popular search
term behind music minecraft beat out
such heavy hitters as beyonce pewdiepie
and movies google also divulged that six
of the top 10 most viewed youtube
channels in the us are gaming related
please direct all congratulations for
minecraft's success to microsoft who now
own the game and the developer mojang
mafia 3 may soon be announced according
to a tweet by a twitter snitch who also
happened to be the lead voice actor for
mafia 2. rick pasqualone aka vito
scaletta tweeted quote might have some
mafia news very soon the game has been
rumored to be in development for over
two years though the 2k games
development studios supposedly working
on the project have seen tumultuous
times of late for what it's worth 2k
games parent company take 2 interactive
said in march 2013 that it has quote an
extensive pipeline of unannounced games
in development the biggest story this
week was the continued refinement and
propagation of virtual reality
peripherals at ces in las vegas this
week i think i said this week twice you
did you're bad damn it
razer announced the osvr an open source
vr headset tailored to not only work
with existing vr software but also a
variety of game engines and other motion
control peripherals some of the other vr
options aren't so promising namely the
bulbous 3d head a comically distended
helmet which gamespot's senior newsman
justin haywald described
unfavorably but the leader of the pack
is still the oculus rift and if you want
to know why be sure to check out our
video on why oculus rift is still the
best vr at ces at gamespot.com
gametech and with that 2015's first week
of gs news comes to a close and i bid
you farewell jess mcdonald and ed tran
are resuming their rightful place on the
news throne next week and as for me i
can't say what gamespot videos i'll end
up in next but for now i'll just ride
off into the sunset until the news needs
me again
i mean it's still pretty light outside
so later is when i'm gonna do the actual
sunset riding and i mean i live to the
east up here so it's going to be more
like away from metaphor you guys you
guys get it